One of the things I learned very early on
as a CEO and entrepreneur was the fact that
I cannot speak the same language to every
audience that I'm communicating with.
For instance, I can't speak to my staff the
way I speak to my vendors, the way I speak
to the media.
It's all different on how you communicate
with them.
And I've made all the mistakes in the world,
and I'm probably going to be making many more
new mistakes, but I finally came out with
a philosophy on how to communicate with these
seven different audiences, these types of
languages you've got to speak.
And once you learn how to be aligned with
the way you communicate with them, you become
more effective.
So let me get right into it.
First of all, let me give it to you in ranking,
exactly on which platform is the most important
to communicate with, all the way to the highest
level, and I'll explain to you why.
Now, you may or may not agree with this, but
this is a philosophy that works for me.
So this is what's worked for me and I'll share
it with you.
So, seven platforms, seven audiences.
#7: How you communicate with to the media.
It's the least important but it's still important.
#6: How you communicate with your vendors.
#5: How you communicate with your investors
#4: How you communicate with your customers
and clients
Some people may say, "Why did Pat put a #4?"
I'll explain to you exactly why.
#3: How you communicate with your partners,
carriers
#2: How you communicate with your staff and
executives
#1: How you communicate with your sales, on
who touches the client the most, how you deal
with your sales force.
So let me get right into it.
#7: Media and Public
One of the challenges with media and public
is, I experienced it early on, when we had
somebody who endorsed me and all of a sudden
all of these different political media platforms
started reaching out to me saying, "You know,
this person's on the back end, investing into
the company" and we had no idea how to respond
because we were just a startup getting started.
Even our competitors were loving this because
they're saying, "Oh, look at what they're
doing, look what's taking place with the company."
So we were kind of cornered.
We had never gone through this before.
And I had to learn how to identify that and
sit back instead of taking things personally
and trying to defend yourself.
Learning how to respond to that issue that's
come up.
So one, the most important advice I can give
you on how to deal with media and public is
to have your message be aligned with your
identity.
Have your message be aligned with your identity.
Let me explain to you what I mean by that.
So, the way that Donald Trump deals with media
works for him.
But if you tried to deal with media the way
Donald Trump deals with media, and it's not
your identity, you're completely going to
flop.
And you're going to make a fool out of yourself,
and your brand, and everybody that is also
representing the brand the way you're representing
the brand.
It's important to be aligned.
Let me get a little bit deeper so this makes
sense to you because you may say, "What's
Pat talking about?"
Listen, think about it this way.
Think about it if I date a girl.
Okay?
And for the first six months I'm acting very
like a tough guy, I'm strong, I'm this, I'm
that and then we start dating and the girl
was attracted to the tough guy Pat.
Right?
A year later, two years later, and she starts
saying, "You're too this, you're too this"
and I start losing my identity and I become
this little softie and then she loses her
attraction to me and we're wondering why,
but the reality is the initial identity she
was turned on by is no longer there.
Does that kind of make sense?
So you've got to make sure you stay the congruent
identity that you really are.
Imagine Apple.
When you and I think about Apple, Apple typically
launches their phone in September.
They come out with a new phone, right?
Like let's just say that the iPhone 7 is going
to come out in September.
If they don't, the identity is changing.
And the way they typically do launches, is
hush, hush, you don't announce anything and
then all of a sudden, the most incredible
phone is coming out.
And then they contact the most biggest famous
bloggers that are technology bloggers and
they give them a little bit of a hint, and
then they write and 17 million people go to
this technology blogger.
It's going to look like this.
It's going to look like that.
And they confuse all of their competitors
and then they say, "Do you know the phone
that came out, the camera can actually read
your feelings and emotions.
And we're like, "oh my gosh.
This one's a terrible iPhone and we throw
this one and we go to the next one and give
this one away to our grandfather or parents
and then we go get the new one.
That's their identity.
It works for them.
Stay true to your identity when dealing with
the media.
And I hope I made sense in this part because
if you're small right now, you're saying,
"I don't have to deal with this type of stuff."
Well, you kind of do when it happens on Yelp
or it happens on different.
. . that's still media to you, so you've got
to know how to communicate with media and
the public.
If you did something wrong, always take responsibility
for it.
It's the first thing that just eliminates
all the other person's ready to come attack
you, "It was our fault.
We take full responsibility for this, we're
going to get better."
Ooooookay.
What do I say next?
Shoot.
They took responsibility, move on.
#6: Vendors
The way I communicate with vendors is a complete
different way than the way I communicate with
partners, and I'll explain to you what I mean
by vendors.
Vendors to me are, I'm booking an event at
a hotel in Las Vegas and there's this girl
that represents us and she's a vendor and
she's going to make $25,000 on the deal.
I am on her case 24/7 to represent me in such
a world class way.
I probably put the most pressure on vendors
than anybody else.
Highest pressure I put on vendors than anybody
else.
Why?
Because anybody that's become a vendor with
me for a long time, you're automatically going
to make a lot of money with me.
Guaranteed.
You're going to make a lot of money with me.
It's just going to happen.
And a vendor, in my mind, they work from home,
they're sitting there, they're with their
kids, they're doing all this other stuff as
vendors, and then [snap].
they land a client like ours and then they're
making automatically $40,000 per year, $30,000
per year, on one account.
So if a vendor I notice gets a little too
comfortable with me, I'm moving on.
I'm moving on.
The types of vendors that I keep to myself
for a very, very long time are the types of
vendors that don't abuse my relationship.
They don't automatically think that I'm a
lock because they already have me and can
use me and abuse me all the time, that is
not going to happen with vendors, at all,
ever.
It just won't happen on our case.
And my staff knows it.
My staff knows that when we have vendors,
we'll typically have multiple vendors that
are shopping for us to give us the best opportunity
because if you only have one vendor, vendors
will typically abuse you because they know
they're the only ones.
I don't mean to be negative to vendors, I've
just done a lot of stuff with vendors and
I've had great vendors and I've had vendors
that I had to fire, and explain to them why
I fired them.
There's a guy that I've been using in Vegas
for the longest time, Marshall.
He's absolutely phenomenal on what he does.
He's a pro, he's a professional.
Every year he does my events, it doesn't matter
where I'm doing it, I trust this guy's feedback
because of the way he does certain things.
I have a lot of value for him.
Now if all of a sudden he tries to abuse the
relationship, obviously, we'll go elsewhere,
but I trust his abilities, as a vendor and
what he does for us.
I use him every single time we have an event,
we pick our dates based on his availability,
because he's a pro that we trust.
So a vendor's relationship to me is pressure,
performance, expectations high.
Just like attorneys, I want my attorneys to
do their best for me.
I want my accountants to do their best for
me.
I expect them to work very hard.
I expect the attorneys to do their part.
These are vendors to me.
Now if a law firm eventually becomes my general
counsel and my legal counsel, now that becomes
a partner.
A vendor to me is someone I use every once
in a while, but not on a monthly basis.
Maybe I use them once every three months or
something like that.
That's a vendor.
Partners are a completely different story
and I'll explain exactly how I treat partners.
#5: How you communicate with investors
Investors have one thing in mind.
Unless the investor is your mom or dad or
it's an uncle, they also care about you, right?
They kind of want to see you win.
If the investor is a former mentor you worked
with for 10 or 15 years, then they invested
in your business, but they also want to see
you win, they want to see you happy.
That's a different story.
Take those out, investors care about one thing,
and one thing only.
How much money you're going to bring back
to them.
That's it.
They care about your health, but it's not
even on their top 10 list.
The only reason they care about your health
is for you not to die so they can get their
money back.
They care about your marriage, but the only
reason they care about your marriage is because
they don't want your marriage to flop because
it's going to disrupt the business.
That's the investor.
They care about whether you're happy or not,
not because they care about your joy, happiness
and all that other stuff, because if you're
happy you're going to perform and get better
results, right?
That's how they think.
So when you speak to investors, it's all logic.
How's the wife doing?
How's the family doing?
All that small talk, they don't care.
They don't care.
I mean, to them it's a complete different
language.
And I like that language because to me it
is a very honest language.
It's actually a very simple language.
It's not a complicated language.
It's purely a logical language you're having
with investors.
So the more you identify from that side, the
more you're able to communicate with them
effectively.
#4: Next, customers.
You know the whole idea about customers are
always right?
It is pretty accurate on the customers being
always right, but there are sometimes that
customers will like to abuse and do whatever
they can and especially nowadays, to just
get out there and people have access to anything
where they can go out there and bash the world
about you.
I heard a stat one time that said if you do
something good, people tell three people.
But if you do something bad, people tell 11
people.
And I understand and I agree with that as
well.
So customers are always right, except for
the one in a hundred instances that they're
just completely disgruntled and they're negative
and no matter what you can't please them.
And you still have to figure out a way to
work with them as well.
We have to work with many, many customers
that, they're not having a good day.
One of our agents didn't treat them well and
we have to get on the phone with them for
an hour.
I got on the phone with one guy and we got
on the phone and he says, "You know why I
didn't like you?"
Listen to this!
This is a conversation I had with this guy
five and a half years ago.
He said, "I don't like you."
I said, "Why is that?"
He said, "Because you believe in capitalism."
I said, "Yes, I do."
He had heard me give a talk on capitalism.
I said, "I've lived in Iran.
I've lived in the complete opposite end of
capitalism and I prefer capitalism.
That's why I came to America as an immigrant."
And he was part of this organization that
was a communistic organization and he hated
me.
And finally I got on the phone with him for
an hour and said, "What's the issue?
Tell me."
This was a very random, weird call.
We had a 45 minute conversation about politics.
Tell me what you think about this.
Why do you believe this way?
Do you know this president.
. . I said, "Listen, most of this stuff I'm
agreeing with you.
The only thing I'm not agreeing with you is
the fact that you think that every business
owner's a crook and they're trying to do bad
things out there."
You work for PF Changs.
They pay your salary.
Imagine if there was no PF Changs.
"I'd work for another company."
But regardless, you're going to work for a
capitalist.
So we had this conversation and we laughed
and kidded and joked.
We had a great conversation.
And then we got off.
He said, "I'm good."
Great.
Three years later he sends me a message on
Facebook after my video goes viral and he
says, "Hey, I remember when you and I spoke,
it's amazing to see you doing very well.
I am now a capitalist."
I mean, it was the most random thing, and
now we have a relationship together.
So customers are right.
You need to make sure you hear them out because
everyone's experience may be different.
But to me, I can do a lot more to make the
customer's experience better if I take care
of my top three.
And I'll explain to you why this is.
#3: The audience to speak the language to
is partners.
Partners to me are very important.
I as an insurance company have a lot of carriers.
So some of them may be carriers that we have
that we can sell, whether it's Nation Wide,
whether it's National Life or all these other
companies and then I have partners.
I have partners that I deal with that, whether
it AIG or whoever it is.
I have partners, right?
There are carriers and then there are partners.
Those who become partners, they are in it
with you.
Now this doesn't mean that one day they can't
turn around because you know how partners
sometimes they bring a new regime and everything
changes and they're not?
They're not partnership secondary or third
and you've got to go find somebody that wants
to be a partner.
But for the most part, when there's a partnership,
things are in a place where both want each
other to win in a big way.
And the way I handle my partners is this.
Look, we both have a couple of things in common.
We need to make sure our customers are happy.
We need to make sure our reps are happy.
If we can have our customers and our reps
happy, you and I are happy.
Yes?
Yes.
Okay, what can we do to make customers' experience
better?
For instance, if I'm Zappos and I'm selling
shoes and I have twenty contracts with shoe
companies, but I have partners and one of
ones -- I'm just throwing a name out there
- is Cole Haan.
Cole Haan and I have a very strong relationship
together because they're my partner, I'm going
to make sure as Zappos that Cole Haan delivers
good products to my customers.
Because if they deliver good products to my
customers, they're happy.
I need to make sure that how Cole Haan treats
the customer when the customer sends a shoe
back and it's missing a sole.
Or it's missing whatever.
It's broken.
Something happened and it's torn.
I need to make sure how they treat my customers
because if my customer, I'm representing them
as a partner.
I need to make sure my customer is happy with
my partner.
So I spend more time making sure the partner
treats the customer right so the customer
doesn't call me for a complaint.
This is why the customer to me is #4.
I put the other three at the top because customer
touch is them more than the customers going
to touch me.
I need to make sure the customer is extremely
satisfied with the partner.
That's why partner is #3.
So the partner part, I literally explain to
the partner, "Listen, we are a team, we're
on the same page.
We need to make this thing better.
What do you need to do to get better?
What do we need to get better?"
The more transparency and honesty are with
me, the more we can improve, but I'm going
to hold you accountable as well for you to
improve.
So let's have a monthly conference call.
We know where you're at, we know what you're
doing.
Boom, both of us are getting better.
#2 is staff and executives.
Staff and executives on how you communicate
with staff and executives.
So remember, staff and executives generally
are on a salary base and then you have sales
that are not, they're on commission base.
So staff and executives they have health,
all this other stuff that is taken care of
and they have a salary.
And then they have an environment and their
hours are pretty predictable hours for the
most part.
I expect a lot from my executives.
A lot from my executives.
If someone works closely with me and they're
an executive they will generally tell you,
"Patrick is on our case until he trusts us.
And that's literally the way it is.
Once I trust your ability, that you have subscribed
to being a leader in life, I leave you alone,
and I simply challenge you and mentor you
and then you give me direction and ideas.
And I challenge you to improve and the next
project, what do we need to do.
I need direction from you.
We're going back and forth.
Right?
But I need to know that I trust you as a leader.
So I'm pushing you as an executive harder
than anybody else to make you become a leader.
The moment you're a leader, my staff is going
to be led by you.
So I need to make sure you become a leader
so you're leading everybody else with the
example that you're setting to them.
So there's an expectation.
I'm doing a video that should be launched
in the next couple of weeks and that video's
going to be Six Things I Expect from My Executives
and I expect that video to come out as well
so you'll find out a little more about my
expectations of my executives.
And with my staff, I'm touching all my staff
members, hey, encouraging them, "How you doing?"
"What's going on?"
Keep it going, you're playing an important
role.
We need to keep developing.
We need to keep getting better, what is your
project this week?
What are you doing?
What's going on with this?
We're working that language as well, but there's
a high expectations from the executives for
them to deliver and to perform.
And I'm constantly teaching the executives
and our staff members that no one's more important
without the sales force, without the customers.
If we don't take care of those two, we don't
have a job and we don't exist.
Make sense?
If the sales force is being taken care of
and the customers are being taken care of,
we have a job.
How well of a job are we doing there?
We're doing good.
Excellent, let's get better.
And the last one which is the most important
language you'll speak to an audience is your
sales force.
And let me explain to you why sales force.
I have meetings here with our staff and let's
just say that staff's going to say, "Man,
you know I want to go home early and I want
to go out there and do this and I want to
go out there and do.
. . " And I say, "Listen, you've been going
home early the last few weeks on Fridays.
What do you think we are?
Do you think we're a $600 billion company,
we're corporate, going golfing from Friday,
Saturday, Sunday?
No, we're trying to be a $600 billion company.
We're not a $600 billion company.
And you're acting like you've already made
it.
And that's not a leader.
That's an entitled person already.
You want to golf?
You go golf on Sunday.
That's totally fine with me.
I don't care if you want to golf.
But we're building something special here.
And so I will always remind our staff that
sales people are in the streets getting rejected,
they're selling, they're marketing, they're
knocking on doors, they're going to families'
house, and they're constantly hearing the
magical words, "N - O." No, no, no, no, no.
We have to be the biggest cheerleaders and
make everything be easier for them.
They need to be tough because when it comes
down to sales, I'm not the one that's necessarily
- I'm a driver with my sales guys but I also
understand because I've been selling all my
life, so I know exactly what it is to go door
to door, I know what it is to work from 6:00
in the morning to midnight, six, seven days
a week.
I know exactly what it is to work 100 hours
per week.
We still do it today when we're working with
the company.
So I love working with my sales guys because
if I make sure my sales guys are trained well,
my customers are happy.
If I teach my guys, my sales guys to have
high expectations and a bigger vision and
think big on what they can do and make more
money, that means we can expand the company
and hire more to give them more support.
If we get our sales guys to work on becoming
leaders and becoming independently leading
their businesses, reading books, developing
themselves all around, they grow and everybody
else grows in the company.
If we have a spirit of competition and we
stay competitive and edgy on the sales side,
we know exactly how to talk among other competitors,
when the competitors want to bash us and say
why they're better than us, etc. etc. which
is a part of the world we're in.
As an entrepreneur in business you've got
to learn how to put your hands up sometimes
and just brawl with competitors.
It is going to happen.
Sometimes you've got to build bridges, but
sometimes they don't want to build bridges
and you've got to say, "Let's go toe to toe
and let's see what we can do and who can deliver
better for the clients."
But to me, at the top of my list, are sales
people because if customers are not happy
and I'm on the phone with them for one hour,
they're typically complaining about who?
Two people.
They're typically complaining about the partner
that didn't give them the service with the
product that was sold to them by who?
A sales person that didn't give them the type
of results that they want.
And, if they were to call on our home office
to talk to our staff members and executives,
they didn't get the customer service they
want, this is why customers to me is #4, because
I need to take care of my right partners and
pick them correctly.
I need to make sure my sales reps are treating
my customers right, and I need make sure that
the staff and executives every time they touch
a customer, they're feeling better about themselves,
not walking away saying, "I'm unhappy with
my experience that I had."
That's why I put sales reps all the way at
the top of my list.
So when you are learning how to communicate
with these guys, and by the way, I can talk
on this subject, literally, I could do an
eight hour talk on this subject right now
and just do Q&As all day long.
And I could go deeper in this subject.
What about if they do this?
What about if say this?
What about if the partner does this?
What about if the vendor does this?
What about if the attorney and the lawyer
does this?
When do you.
. . this is an eight-hour subject I'm putting
together in I don't know, Paul, how many minutes
is it already?
Is it like 20 minutes or 19 minutes?
22 minutes, whatever the timeline is, yeah,
20 minutes.
We're going to get deeper into this on future
projects that we're going to have, but at
this point I just want to put this on the
back of your mind when you're thinking about
how to communicate with people.
Let some of these ideas.
help you in communicating with these different
departments, whether it's the public, whether
it's a vendor, whether it's investors, whether
it's customers, partners, staff and executives,
sales people -- learn how to communicate this
language and you'll do better with them.
Paul, send me my pillow.
Send me my pillow real quick, buddy.
Hey, guys, we've got to get to 100,000 subscribers.
I've been getting a lot of great messages
from some of you guys strategizing and helping
us out.
We want to get this channel, which I believe
is the number one channel on YouTube for entrepreneurs.
I really believe that.
I've sized up my competition and Iook at exactly
what type of content they put together.
I believe this is the number one channel on
YouTube for entrepreneurs that want to learn
how-to principles.
Not just motivational.
There are a lot of great sites on motivation,
and there are a lot of great YouTube channels
that create incredible content for motivation
they can go to.
But when I want to know, "How do I do this?"
there's not a lot of how-to.
We are the number one how-to channel on YouTube
for entrepreneurship, I believe more than
any other channel on YouTube.
And we're just getting started.
We need your help to get to 100,000 subs.
I think right now we're at 44,000 and some
change on YouTube subs and we want to get
to 100,000 by August 31.
I am launching a big project in August that
we're going to launch.
It's going to be an international project
that we're launching.
We bought a domain name for $100,000 and we'll
be launching that here pretty soon, so we
need your help to help us get to 100,000 subs
by August 31.
So if you haven't subscribed to our channel
You can subscribe right here to the channel.
If you're watching this video on a completely
different platform and it's not my website
or YouTube, you can always come back to PatrickBetDavid.com
and then if you have any questions and comments
about this topic, which I'm sure you will,
post your comments on the bottom.
Thanks for watching, everybody, take care.
Bye bye.